rapidly-expanding impeachment inquiry by
House Democrats into president Trump's
dealings with Ukraine on Friday the
president's former ambassador to Ukraine
testified before a congressional panel
about how she was removed from her job
this as the New York Times reports
federal prosecutors were investigating
mr. Trump's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani for his involvement in Ukraine
the president went to the campaign trail
in Louisiana to vent his frustrations
and to rally his base Nataly brand
begins our coverage and oldest she is at
the White House where President Trump
returned late last night Natalie good
morning good morning to you Jeff and
this campaign rally came just hours
after the president announced a partial
trade deal with China while that was
mentioned last night it certainly wasn't
the focus it was the impeachment inquiry
that had the president most fired up
describing it in profane terms they know
they can't win an election day so
they're pursuing an illegal invalid and
unconstitutional impeachment President
Trump again railed against House
Democrats as he rallied supporters for
the second night in a row for nearly
three years Democrats have waged a
non-stop battle to overturn your vote
overruled your voice override your
values nearly three weeks into the
formal impeachment inquiry ten subpoenas
have now been issued with deadlines next
week for the president's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani on Friday the
president appeared to distance himself
from Giuliani well I don't know I
haven't spoken to Rudy I spoke to him
yesterday briefly
he's a very good attorney and he has
been my attorney Yesha CBS News has
learned Giuliani will stay on mr.
Trump's legal team but will not
participate in matters related to
Ukraine on Thursday to Giuliani
associates Lev Parnas and eager Freeman
were arrested on federal campaign
finance charges while Giuliani was not
named in the indictment the two men are
linked to his efforts to investigate
former Vice President Joe Biden
and his son hunter as the impeachment
investigation escalates the ongoing
trade war with China appeared to ratchet
down Friday we knew that we were going
to have a very successful phase one the
president and China's Vice Premier
announced an agreement in principle on
phase one of a trade deal while
specifics have not been released the
president says China has agreed to some
intellectual property protections and
will step up agricultural purchases to
an additional forty to fifty billion
dollars in return the US will hold off
on the tariff hike that had been
scheduled to take effect next week on
two hundred and fifty billion dollars
worth of Chinese imports now a decision
has not been made on the tariffs
scheduled for December and the
administration acknowledges much work
remains to be done in the weeks and
months ahead phase one of this deal must
still be finalized before negotiators
can begin to tackle phase two Michelle
all right Natalie thank you